TODAY. YOU NEED THIS BED.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: ROBERT MILLER'S
INVESTIGATION WAS SUPPOSED TO
FIND EVIDENCE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION OR MAYBE IT WAS SYRIA
AND COLLUSION.
ANYWAY, IT WAS TREASONOUS
BEHAVIORS THAT THREATENED THE
REPUBLICANS MAMA THOSE THE WHOLE
POINT.
A YEAR LATER, IT'S NOT EVEN
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S APPARENTLY AN ALL-PURPOSE
LOOK AT THE     THE PRESIDENTS P
LOOK AT THE     THE PRESIDENTS R
LOOK AT THE     THE PRESIDENTS O
LOOK AT THE     THE PRESIDENTS A
LOOK AT THE     THE PRESIDENTS L
FINANCIAL AND SEX LIFE.
THE FBI WAS HUNTING FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT STORMY DANIELS
AND THE EXCESS HOLLYWOOD CASE.
RATHER THAN ANYTHING THAT
MATTERS.
DO YOU WANT TO KNOW, DOES THE
PUBLIC WANT TO KNOW A LOT MORE
ABOUT THE PRESIDENTS SEX LIFE?
>> IT NO!
I LIKE DONALD TRUMP, BUT I HAVE
ZERO INTEREST IN HEARING ANY
MORE ABOUT DONALD TRUMP'S SEX
LIFE.
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
STORMY DANIELS, I DON'T WANT TO
HEAR ABOUT ANY OF THE OTHERS.
I'VE KNOWN DONALD TRUMP A LONG
TIME AND I'VE ALWAYS TAKEN HIM
TO BE A MAN THAT'S BEEN MARRIED
THREE TIMES AND HAS REGULARLY
BOASTED FOR FIVE DECADES OF HIS
LOVE OF WOMEN.
THE IDEA THAT IT'S SOMEHOW
SHOCKING OR RELEVANT TO ANYTHING
INVOLVING HIS RESIDENCY THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS A LADIES' MAN I
THINK IS RIDICULOUS.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE SEEING,
WE HAVE A
BROTHER THAT'S HER BRITISH ARMY.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT BAFFLES
ME TWICE A YEAR, HE GOES TO A
RIVER IN THE DARKEST, MOST
REMOTE PARTS OF THE ISLAND AND
HE STANDS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
RIVER AND HE HAS A ROD AND HE
HAS BAIT AND HE'S REALLY THERE
TO CATCH A SALMON, BUT HE NEVER
ACTUALLY CATCHES SALMON.
HE CATCHES BITS OF WOOD THAT
SMASHES HIM IN THE BACK OF THE
HEAD FOR THE NEXT FIVE HOURS OR
HE CATCHES THE LITTLE TINY
MINNOWS OR BITS AND PIECES THAT
FLOAT ON THE RIVER.
HERE'S THE POINT.
ISN'T THIS REALLY WHAT WE'RE
SEEING HERE?
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION WAS
SET UP TO CATCH THE BIG SALMON.
DONALD TRUMP ED COLLUSION.
HE WORKED WITH THE RUSSIANS TO
FIX THE ELECTION.
IF THAT WAS TRUE, IT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY SERIOUS AND WOULD
CERTAINLY LEAD TO THE END OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
TO DATE, WE HAVE SEEN NO
EVIDENCE AT ALL THAT I'VE SEEN
ANY CLEAR EVIDENCE THAT HE
COLLUDED WITH RUSSIA TO FIX THE
ELECTION.
WHAT WE'RE NOW SEEING AS IT
REACHES IS A SEGWAY AWAY INTO
HIS SEX LIFE, INTO HIS LOYALIST
ACTIVITIES.
MY GUESS IS THEY'RE PANICKING,
THEY'RE DESPERATE, THEY NEED TO
NAIL DONALD TRUMP ON COLLUSION,
THEY HAVEN'T GOT THAT.
THEY'RE FISHING, THEY'RE HOPING
WHEN HE STANDS IN THAT WATER,
HE'LL CATCH SOMETHING, ANYTHING.